[Music]
only 11 seconds of one logo this movies
from 1974 people where did we go wrong
just because I'm pissed off now I'm
gonna give an undeserved sin to this
movie
it looks like Paul ascribes to do you
take a picture it'll last longer
philosophy with his wife gonna show this
Danny what are you revenge porn Hawaii
airport's the death wish
holy Sh this musics disorienting I know
the movie takes a dark turn shortly but
this ship is like horror movie fanfare
who the hell did this score King a
Herbie Hancock a guy from Valyrian in
the city of a thousand planets the
seventh ring and hold Leng she dies soon
goddamn this movies only been going on
for three minutes but they make the trip
from Hawaii to New York seem as long as
it actually is in real life man I sure
glad we've got the time to see all the
mundanes that the Kerr sees do upon
arriving at home like checking the
fucking mail otherwise how would we know
who the head grip is for this movie they
travel together they eat together and
they sleep together yep they're
definitely a married couple I'm glad the
opening credits could hammer that home
force the hell is this future tech where
you can turn off both bed lamps at the
same time as Paul have an Amazon echo a
Google home a cloudless clapper you want
to know what was happening while you and
Joanna we're living it up in Maui or
Cowie or Yahweh whatever it is
apparently in the 70s Malia was still so
exotic that it sounded like it came from
Lord of the Rings and to simply call it
by name was something that nerds did you
are such a bleeding-heart liberal Paul
stickum in concentration camps that's
what I say movie predicts roughly 86
percent of Twitter content but what this
city needs is more cops than people
no one could pay the taxes now here's a
cash register to drive home the point
about taxes
wow these assholes need to get on the
same mayhem page considering this thug
puts the hand back before continuing the
store shenanigans discount Jeff Goldblum
dad we got trouble trouble you and Cal
don't tell me about it person interrupts
someone before they get the chance to
tell them what's really going on cliche
also why is his son-in-law calling it
wasn't the cops or the hospital already
have called Paul where they cut stabbed
went
no sir the speed a-- officer exposition
is extremely nonchalant about delivering
this convenient information even but
mused what they tell you about lunch the
last two minutes of this movie have been
paul asking jack what happened a jack
saying i don't know
now apparently he knows at least not
much I mean Jesus get on with it the
most first he has no information then he
plays the pronoun game with what he does
know the officer said the tower wasn't
making much sense
two maybe three men they she opened the
door to let them in because she thought
it was the delivery boy from the
supermarket yeah Carol must have been in
a total days to tell that cop that
cockamamie story your wife is alright
you probably don't give a shit about
your mother-in-law though so that's 100%
good news luckily everyone remember to
bring their black funeral umbrellas
today instead of their Debbie Reynolds
singing in the rain waltz it's time I
went to my own I have to sum I mean it's
been two whole days you gotta move on I
might even start dating again dude I
know New Yorkers honk a lot but at a
fucking funeral this is mr. Paul Pierce
at case number eighty-eight for his wife
and daughter were assaulted so why does
Joe continue to look so goddamn happy
about it I've know you mr. Kersey right
now mr. Kersey have a seat mr. Kersey
one thing I like to do when I'm on a
case is call someone by name three times
within five seconds it's a fun thing I
do just ignore me but I haven't been
able to pick the faces out of my book
the three guys who assaulted Joanne and
Carol definitely have criminal records
and one of them is Jeff Goldblum don't
tell me they couldn't pick that dude out
of a mug book are you getting the most
out of life and retire Amy it's in times
like these one has to buckle down and
drink a glass full of grief milk
wow what a massive coincidence that this
loud theft happens just when Paul was
looking out the window during his net
new milk jug also how they did this dude
gets such great parking in the city I
mean look at the size of that space the
spot is so good the car owner probably
deserved a break in back in the 70s New
York had a if you see something close
the blinds policy twenty dollars in
quarters please Paul just read the
vigilante handbook which states that
when you start vigilante aim start with
the sock full of quarters you want a
whale on shoplifters first then work
your way up to pickpockets can they give
you an answer in about a week
and besides New York is a cesspool of
crime and nobody cares and I've got a
lot of ass to kill how the hell do I
remind her of that
look I know Charles Bronson was a badass
pan was in some classic movies but all
I'm saying is there's a reason he never
starred in a Shakespearean production
don't make it tough for me this is
son-in-law character calls Paul dad so
much it's a wonder that Paul didn't
start his murderous spree several years
ago Charles Bronson in there taking of
the m16 10th Avenue bus Jesus Paul is
looking for any reason to use that sock
full of quarters isn't he turn around
Paul stumbles into 1974 New York and
gets accosted by a mugger I mean come on
guys New York is not like this anymore
Rudy Giuliani and Travis Bickel cleaned
up the city I mean oh this is really
1974 but I saw a record player in Jack's
apartment didn't those just come out
last year yeah that's a $20 bitch-slap
right there quarters bitch holy Sh just
imagine what $40 worth the quarters
would do death wish tutorial mode you
know the way that's racist
[Music]
looks like the director and the sound
effects supervisor had a conflict about
the appropriate amount of moving I got
ideas about building yep this revenge
story definitely has time to delve into
Paul's architectural relationship with
this cowboy developer that's what I wish
safar talks back to motel I have no
doubt this guy's an important person in
Tucson but they just let him drive his
car into the studio a lot like this tell
you what you try driving your car inside
Disneyland and tell me what they say
because I have charges pending and I
want to trip them up and court-martial
hey man Westworld really got me after
you'll Brunner got through with it geez
if they get any tighter on Paul's face
we'll be able to see a cellular
structure you know the scene ain't half
bad the people watching this don't feel
the need to do anything because they're
simply watching a show but Paul sees
that in everyday life people let real
violence go on all the time and feel
powerless to stop it so it makes sense
this triggers something in Paul and
he'll I want to move ass in for it it's
a god damn much hoopla from the gun
control people at the nation's candy
it's amazing how dated this film is
sensible gun control has been a part of
the American fabric for so long it's
hard to believe there was a time people
had to fight for better laws didn't aim
say he was going up to the club for
dinner tonight
isn't this the club but where the hell
are the other members and is the food
served at the range did they have to
kill their own dinners damn it I have so
many questions about this gun club
as a CEO and medical unit commanding
officer huh conscientious objector
oh is that what the CEO stands for in
the military because someone might think
that term is a bit misleading in
seventies movies man was that cutaway it
lasted less than a second and it was
weird it's all right sweetheart
I'll go murder some fools and that'll
get you back on your feet movie once
again treats us to some hot returning
from a trip male action Jesus how does
such a short movie feel so goddamn long
random goofballs were somehow already
able to see you the 2018 Deathwish
remake look I know it's dangerous in the
city and all but it only takes a few
minutes for Paul to find someone with a
raging crime boner also it's amazing
that in 1974 along with the conversation
there were two movies where someone on
top of the hill followed another person
at the bottom of a hill one was a
fantasy sequence sure was with the hill
following back in 1974 also why would
this thug be targeting a dude that's in
relatively good shape and is looking
right at it isn't the element of
surprise important as is picking an easy
mark the studio's criminally all wrong
Ebola wait there are a million crimes
happening in the city every day right so
why would this one killing of a societal
miss grant take up the entirety of the
front page ah the blood effects of the
1970s they were the digitally removed
mustache in Justice League of the day
are these the same nuns from earlier are
the nuns like the oranges and the
Godfather where they foreshadow bad
events or did they walk all the way from
Manhattan to Long Island over the past
few days okay the killings are important
but this looks like everyone in the
precinct gathered for the speech surely
the secretaries or the auxilary staff
have other things to do right it's as if
trouble is attracted to Paul right now
if trouble and Paul were in a love story
we'd call it serendipity apparently
these thugs like to warm up with several
seconds of good old staring dude you can
walk between cars for a reason one is if
you kill two people and want to get away
with it you can walk off one of the cars
that don't have dead people in it which
appears to be the work of the person New
York news media have dubbed the vigil at
a term so vague that you might not even
call it a name at all it's like calling
a robber if the robber or calling a band
led by levon Helm the band it has been
confirmed at the sand gun a thirty-two
pistol which was used in the previous
three homicide was used last night hang
on Paul previously killed four people in
two other incidents so either way the
chief is looking at this wrong back in
1974 people watch TV with a strangely
projected image directly on the TV
rather than the image
actually coming from the TV we couldn't
get named Fred suck the vigilantes
brochures really Paul wasn't wearing
gloves when he shot the subway muggers
and that's fucking cellophane right
there so why there no prints on it this
movie came out in July of 1974 Leonardo
DiCaprio and told me McGuire did not
exist David Blaine did though
coincidence
Booker Booker did Paul stake this place
out before going in did he know that
this diner was a hotbed of criminal
activity and potential muggers I mean
judging from this movie New York was
made up of 56% muggers back in the day
Paul passes three people in the subway
stop and that is all the people in New
York in this subway station in a world
traffic area Paul not only finds muggers
to kill but also finds the pockets of
New York with no witnesses
damn I think the main reason guns are
outlawed in New York City is the booming
switchblade lobbies keeping them out cop
does nothing to detain this random dude
that's standing right next to the dead
body oh well I guess he definitely
didn't get on this train that just
closed its doors got to get back to my
routine of horrible copy exact words I
cut that motherfucker
I hit him I don't know if I should
remove us soon for that line or add one
I guess I'll go to the default the two
men have been identified both had long
criminal records man it sure is good for
Paul that all the assholes he's killed
so far have been assholes and not just
desperate hungry poor people who today
successfully defended herself against
two muggers with an unusual weapon oh
yeah these people who have been inspired
by Paul are definitely not gonna get
murdered using those types of weapons
the fuck is wrong with these folks who
gathers to talk in a stairwell at a
cocktail party you notice it kills more
blacks and whites and from this cocktail
party FoxNews was born conscientious
objectors are unlikely with galantis we
got a finger yeah over there patrolman
Joe Chow what the fuck is that about
is Joe a bad cop does this detective
hate black people why did he say that
guys name like that bloody paper towel
sniffing you're being watched
dial-tone after the other person has
hung up cliche Paul is contemplating
quitting his life as a vigilante so why
is poor music play it's been at least a
few weeks since the break-in and this is
supposedly a nice building but they
haven't at least washed the fucking
spray paint off the walls it was only
three rings what if he'd been in the
skirt where does Paul keep all his
bullets they didn't find any in his
apartment and we never see him reloading
the gun but he's fired at least 13 shots
during his rampage and the revolver can
only house six shells it's we're in the
last 20 minutes of this movie or the
detective chasing after Paul but the
powers that be don't want to arrest him
they just want to scare him out of being
a vigilante I mean is the detectives
main purpose here to catch Paul in the
act where he'll be forced to arrest him
I'm not sure what's at stake here but
the third time today Paul walks past a
billboard advertising a magazine that
directly relates to this story I think
this movie was once called three
billboards reminding the audience what
this movie is about over new york new
york where that character description
written in the margins of this
screenplay is accidentally said out loud
as dialog I thought muggings were down
by like 50% and if that's the case
shouldn't it be way down in this
neighborhood where most of the vigilante
attacks have been happening don't the
muggers in the cities spread the word at
their weekly meetings
Paul shoots at the guy with a knife
first even though the dude at the top of
the stairs had a fucking gun trained on
him does he have a major issue with
afros or something even though he's been
a crack shot this whole time Paul whips
out his finest storm trooper aim to set
up the final act of the movie seriously
blood effects in the 70s were so bad I
genuinely thought this was paint not
just in real life but in the movie too
Paul Kersey briefly morphs into Anton
sugar in this scene I mean seriously
he simply will not stop until he's
murdered this dude that he's never met
before tonight hey Phil you and Paul
who's never given any of these criminals
any chance to survive decides to turn
this last killing into a old-timey
western duel also get your rooster
cogburn out of my death wish gambit they
tell me on the radio you have to see me
Paul Kersey
god dammit do you have something to say
some say it
this motherfucker buries the lead and
tells the detective he got Paul's
address when in fact he found Paul's gun
there's no reason to be this way other
than extending the movie's runtime and
perhaps speculating that this actor will
one day star and this is spinal tap
Kenneth transfer to another city and
I'll drop this gun in the river boy sure
is nice that we wrapped that whole
carols in a catatonic state story line
up
we want you to get out of New York
babban and lean and make four more
sequels to this fucking movie the first
reports we have any gas lighting
murdered a lot of people in the last few
weeks for minor offenses without any
information about their background or
remorse for my actions weird
[Music]
well I'm gonna give you a vacation a
vacation from my problems - five my
father introduced me to a friend of his
and for no reason at all I hit him right
in the stomach all my strength he died a
year later
hey mister got a match yeah my butt and
your butt the numbers will go to 11
does that mean it's louder isn't any
louder well it's one louder isn't it
Oh mess with the bull young man you'll
get the horns fill your hand grilled
cheese
fill me a cheese